all right iris
yes iris oh where did you grow up where
are you from originally
i was born in cuba
i grew up um yes in the united states
california mainly so you came to the us
when
1962 from cuba
like it was part of a
program it's called the peter the peter
pan flight and they called it the peter
pan flight because
it was just a little flight from uh cuba
to miami where um
a lot of children you know uh got on
airplanes and
the united states and cuba made some
kind of a deal that uh they would help
some of the children to have a better
life so
you know they they brought children i
think between the ages of five and
i think seven or that's where there's a
little bit of confusion about my age and
stuff because i'd
they may have lied on my paperwork to
make me eligible
so i'm not sure about the date but i
know it was august the 2nd 1962 when we
arrived at um
miam in miami
and um i was five and my sister was
seven
my mom put us on a plane and we were
supposed to be reunited like in
three months i think they said and uh
it didn't happen right away we were
away from each other for a long you know
for like five or six years
who raised you at that point uh we
went to the catholic charities in miami
and then from there they distributed us
to different states
in the united states and we ended up in
los angeles
where we got picked up at lax by a
foster foster parents
mother and father and they picked us up
and took us to our new place to live in
watts
where there was a lot of things going on
but i didn't speak english at all
and um
so there was a lot of stuff i didn't i
could hear things but i didn't didn't
really bother me or affect me the way
they did other people because i didn't
know what was going on
you didn't understand it
i did not understand it i was i began
to have what they call you know that
culture shock almost immediately i was
oh i walked around like does my eyes
like this all the time because
it was everything was weird food was
weird and you're missing your your
parents i'm sure
i think i did
you know i i had uh very a lot of bad
mad days you know
uh i was frustrated uh
like
when things didn't work out in certain
foster homes they come and move you and
they put you in this like holding place
it's kind of like a jail
until they figure out where they're
going to put you how was the foster
family that you went to
they were
very abusive they were abusive from the
time they picked us up at the airport
my sister was
i don't think we'd ever been in a
vehicle before and you know in cuba it's
like it's an island you know and we were
poor so
my mom never my mom never even learned
how to ride a bicycle so we i think that
that was the first time we were in a
vehicle
and my
my sister got carsick
and the foster mother had
her husband pulled over to the side of
the road and she sat next to my sister
and she put her head in the
vomit and she told her you know
eat it and don't do it again and you
know my sister and do it again and you
know back and forth and
i was like
it was driving me crazy because i knew i
felt bad for her you know and her eyes
were just
you know she's always been like sick
sick to her stomach you know from then i
learned you know that she was had a
delicate stomach
and i thought that was really mean for
them to do
and i think that we were maybe had lice
or something because they they
completely changed the way we looked
they shaved our heads so i'm thinking
maybe they did it because we had some
kind of thing going on and then they
dressed us like boys
you know and we had these dresses that
we came to united states with and every
once in a while when someone you know
would visit us they would put those
dresses on us but any other time we were
you know we were
jean we just we look like boys all the
time
yeah
um
and we we were told this is the united
states you speak english you know
and
i wanted to but i i didn't know how and
i remember the first hot dog i ate i was
like
oh my god i told my i started eating on
my sister's food anytime she they'd
bring something weird out i'd be like
okay i'll eat it you know so i'd eat her
food and stuff and then when i couldn't
we started throwing it behind the
refrigerator and one time the foster
mother found it and boy we were in
trouble
a lot of trouble i got in a lot of
trouble at that house actually
um i think i rebelled i my sister would
say no no but she this lady
would get up in the at five o'clock in
the morning and go to church she was
catholic
and
you know every chance i gotta go in her
room i was just curious about the way
she was and everything
and uh she was very mean i think the
meanest well she did two really mean
mean things to me that that
were very powerful and one of them was
um
i started having pp problems i think
from nerves or something and it was like
my prayer every night
please please let me make me let me make
it to the bathroom you know and every
day she'd be like right there when i
woke up and i'd go
and then she'd pull the sheets down and
she'd say
you did it again you know
and then so she would take my clothes
off and she'd put a like a rubber
panty on me and she had made this cage
that she put outside on the street like
inside the yard up against the fence
where people walked
and
um
she'd leave me there while she went to
church and she did her thing i don't
know how many hours it was you know
but i remember uh
i remember the feeling that i'd get
because i'm naked and i just got this
plastic thing on
and i was in the corner of it and some
you know some people would come by and
they'd they'd laugh or uh
some kids would be like that's you know
but there's nothing worse than when
somebody like feels sorry for you when
they like
this lady used to go by and she she
would shake her head and i'd be like no
it was it would feel like
firm you know like oh my god don't don't
don't feel like that you know but that
was that was really really difficult
and no matter how i tried
you know my daughter and i saw this
movie where
the kid had a pp problem too
and um the mom hung up the sheets
outside
and i thought boy that would have been a
nice thing for you know and one they
made it to the toilet she had this
beautiful crochet thing on the toilet
and the lid closed so i made it to the
toilet but i sat on the thing and i i
peeped on that so now i'm in trouble for
doing that you know but i made it to the
bathroom
you know and then one day she had this
i was going to school or some i don't
know where because we used to walk down
to alameda down the middle to go to
school by ourselves and i'm at our
intersection with and there's this boy
there and he's cussing at me and i was
cussing back at him and he decides to
push me in the middle of the street and
when he pushes me in the street this big
rig
comes by and
tosses me around i don't get run over or
anything it just goes like
you know and i'm like hopping around and
stuff and then when it stops you know by
that time there's police there and
everything and they're all looking at me
and i'm looking at them and they're
trying to talk to me and they're like
she's sick there's there's something
wrong she's uh in shock because i wasn't
talking about i didn't know what to say
you know i was just looking at them like
you know but they took me to the
hospital and i was at the hospital for a
long time while they tried to figure out
i guess who i was and whose kid i was
and uh i came i remember coming home
with the typical like
the kid in the front seat of a cop car
with the hat on eating an ice cream but
i was in trouble i was in a lot of
trouble and she while i was gone
she made this device in them a
in a pantry
and
when i got when i got there she put me
on it and it was like this thing that
held my arms and my leg you know i was
just i was like hanging but not
like hanging
and um and then she just she i don't
even know how she
i don't i don't remember getting there
you know i just remember being up there
and my sister it was her birthday
and i could hear him singing happy
birthday and stuff and and she my
sister's like i'm gonna take my sister a
piece of cake and i was like
i didn't want her to see me
and you know she's like she's got ah
she's walking through the hallway you
know with this plate with a piece of
cake on it and she's looking for me and
then she finds me and she's like and i'm
like
okay
boy because if you don't go away they're
gonna do this to you too you know and
she's like she walks backwards you know
and she's
like wow and i was like that was kind of
i don't know it was weird i don't know i
don't remember them putting me up there
or taking me down but it was like
a really weird thing you know really
weird thing to happen how did you leave
this family because you you how long
were you with this family i i think we
were close to two years there
yeah and it was stuff like that like we
got
i guess the um welfare department or
something you know they delivered gifts
and stuff to us and
um
oh yeah there was one yeah one
they had an attic and when at christmas
time in the holidays and stuff their
family like her daughter and their kids
would come so they'd move us out of out
of this room that we were in and um
and they put us in the attic that had
like a bed that didn't have any mattress
or anything on it and i my sister and i
would just hold on to each other looking
at that
that attic window the whole night
yeah and
there was a light like a street light
shining on her billboard you know and
she and i just stayed there all night
long because we were scared there was
rats in there and we were cold and
everything and waited you know until
they finished doing what they were doing
and stuff and
um
and we loved the foster dad even though
he was abusive to us
and when we got when i got like
like okay this man is not right because
uh
she finally had said he was gonna have
him spank us
you know when we got in trouble and so
he took us in in this little room and
he'd sit us on the bed and be like okay
i have the belt
i'm going to hit the bed with the with
the belt
and um
you cry
you guys just you know what you know so
we're like okay
so he you know he like would hit the bed
and then her and i would go we were
looking at each other and and we go ah
you know all this crime but then he
would do like a horrible thing to us he
would he would he would stick his
fingers in our bottoms and our and our
vaginas
and so i let me to kind of
like okay i don't know if i want to get
punished by her by him you know
he was also the one that he had a garage
and he uh like all of our christmas
presents it went in there and my sister
would
beg you know can i please play with my i
didn't give a [ __ ] about any of that
stuff but she really was attached to
some of it and they let her see it on
christmas day and then they packed it
all up so he would let her like scroll
through there you know and look at her
things and
you know tyler gave her hopes that maybe
one day she'd be able to you know
to play with them again so
uh one day i don't know from where we
got a
visit from a social worker
and they they told the foster parents i
guess somebody called her something
because they said that it was weird that
we
said yes ma'am and no ma'am and that
that was all we know we said
and um they took us to this place in los
angeles a big
huge place i think it's still there and
uh put us in this room full of toys and
books and a real nice calm place
and i ran immediately like it was a long
like a real long room and my sister and
this lady were talking
and she started asking my sister
questions about you know the foster home
and my sister was like oh i love my my
father and my mother you know
and i'm looking at her and she's she was
asking her you know questions like are
they mean to you do they do anything you
know my sister was like oh no
and i was hearing this and i was like
that's not true you know and from across
the room you know and i said they do
this and and she's like no don't don't
say nothing don't you know and
you know the social worker went and
started talking to me my sister was like
nervous and everything there and i just
i said everything that was going on with
us and they removed us from there
and they took us to
i'm not sure some
not a foster home but um we we went to
mclaren hall we went to maryvale
we were in all the places all the places
you could possibly go to
uh well you know
they
they put us back in the system
or
hold on to us you know to find another
place
but a lot of confusion and i didn't when
we were studying i remember them talking
about um ponce de leon and i the teacher
would you know talk to other kids about
their relationship to certain
discoverers and stuff and you know she
said you ponce de leon is related to you
you know and i so i always told
everybody you know he was
i was his niece or something like that
you know but i was a little bit curious
about it and i didn't
quite understand why
i spoke spanish
but i wanted to speak english so bad you
know and i i said i was always going to
hold on to you know to that
to the language i it was really
important to me for some reason and i
knew that i had a
people or something somewhere else you
know and that this was just you know for
for a little while
and we went to uh
halfway home
yeah mclaren hall was a really that was
a real tough place
uh a lot of children they were crying
and
it was crazy yeah and you were reunited
with your
your actual parents eventually um not uh
not right away no
um we probably were in
maybe
four
like there was this one place called
hathaway home freaks for orphans or for
children in pasadena
and there
it was kind of
a place i think that people that were
looking to adopt you know
children went to because i remember you
know people i remember the foster
parents that got me from there
i saw them a few times before i ended up
at their home so i know that
something you know
was happening you know and uh
from there you know my sister and i we
had we were in different cottages
because she was older they separate you
know and i remember when um
these these foster friends said they did
you know they told me oh you have you
have a new home
oh yeah and this place uh they had like
real good structure they had you know
everything was good except for one thing
you know i had to have these piano
lessons right they wanted me to you know
know how to do music and stuff and i
wasn't interested in it at all but
um
so i go in there and i'd be like
and then she'd give me a test and and
because they always took me out of the
pool
you know it was like that was my
favorite thing to do you know to be
swimming and then i could hear they call
me over the thing they said time for you
to go everybody would go to their
different therapy and music and all that
but i thought that was really funny i
thought i'd put it all over and i took
probably for maybe three years
um piano and i could i can't play
nothing
and no but i passed all my tests and
everything but i just did it like okay
here you go you say
i don't like this i don't want to be
here you know i used to get so mad
hathaway home was a good a good place i
i got to meet i got to meet a lot of
very different people you know they were
all kids but there were people too i
remember getting sick i think i got like
the measles there and i was in a
wheelchair and i hated it
you know and my favorite day there was
on sundays because we got um
we had to play outside and it was a real
pretty area the grounds are real they're
beautiful
and um i played with all the boys and
they used to all follow me because i'd
get this big plastic bag and then fill
it up with the snails
and then i'd say somebody get the salt
you know and so we'd go up on this hill
and then
they they were amazed the boys were
looking at me like look what i could do
and i pour the salt on the
snails and they were amazed like they
looked for me on sundays you know
i just didn't like the baloney
sandwiches and i never have been able to
eat bologna with mustard
at all that was like their lunch on
sundays
um i think
my mom came okay i was in and out of a
few foster homes and i became a runaway
during that time also
um
the social worker would take take me to
a home and i i could tell you i learned
how to know like within the first three
minutes four minutes that i was there
while they're talking to each other
i
would look around and and i'd know
like what kind of treatment i was going
to get or what so like as soon as she
left i was at the door
and i would just be like i'm going to go
sit on the path you know and then
i never knew directions or anything but
somebody told me just you know i said if
you want to go like to the beach because
we lived in culver city in santa monica
and stuff and um i i no matter where i
was uh i always made it back over there
but sometimes it would take me days
you know and you're talking about like a
9 10 11 year old runaway
you know who survived
i i had uh nothing ever happened to me
on the streets
everything happened in
those homes you know
your parents
oh
so i never got it had communication or
anything uh from them
i finally after several placements and
stuff i i was
put in a wonderful wonderful foster home
with a
from just a mom and dad and they had
raised uh two two sons who were
pediatricians and they wanted a daughter
they wanted a daughter that was a
pediatrician they had everything i mean
i'm i'm not kidding you i at that age i
was already under i was like yes
this is good you know i understood like
okay i want to be somebody you know i
can do this
and
right when i was very secure very stable
there and i'm you know not to put my mom
down i love my mom and everything
i was taken out when they said your
mom's you know arriving you'll have to
you're gonna have to leave and i was
like i was looking at my foster parents
like
how can you be so mean don't don't don't
make me go i want to see my mom but i
don't want to leave here i i you know i
understood the stability you know and
and that i had a plan and
uh everything and
the the day came and um
oh yeah
when i first met my mom
at
the airport
okay my mom came she had no teeth she
had her head was almost completely
shaven because she had this she had made
this promise to one of the saints in
cuba that if she landed on you know
ground
soil on american soil to be reunited
with your children she would shave her
head and everything and she had i'm
almost like 100 100 pounds she was real
you know
poor you could tell you know and so when
they said well look your mom you know i
was looking at i'm like no that's not my
mom you know and
it was weird like just looking like
looking at her and like
you know it was like weird like
oh my god that is my mom you know
little by little you know i was still
really scared you know but i i
she had this little baby and she was
really cute and um
i i told myself well maybe maybe i
should just love that little baby like a
doll
and and maybe she'll you know she loved
me too you know
so i went from that stability to a hotel
floor
on top of all my clothes that was my bed
you know like i said i'm not saying
anything derogatory anything about my
mom it was just that's what it came down
to you know and i remember laying in
that in that uh hotel room because she
was in a hotel and it was pitch black
and my mom had this radio on was
communication cuba
you know where everybody was like you
just stay on it to listen to see if any
of your family members have been you
know
released or whatever and i remember
looking at her cigarette my mom smoked
like one cigarette after another and i'd
watched that light go you know from
like wow she'd do that you know and so
like
probably a year or so later i was
smoking i wanted cigarettes and she
would let me have them you know in cuba
it was no big deal to drink a bunch of
coffee and have cigarettes at age 10 and
stuff
oh yeah i'll tell you i'll tell you
when i was reunited with my mom my mom i
had a brother or have a brother who was
um
i think he was 18. i was i think i was
10 going on 11 when we were reunited
and um
my mom left me
at home i was a girl that was
for my age
i was built you know what i'm saying i
had i had a
like if you walked if you looked at me
from behind you would think i was older
and stuff but when i would turn around
like
you know men would be like oh [ __ ] you
know they kind of walk away because
they'd realize you know my age and stuff
anyway so my mom went to uh go do
laundry one night
and she leaves me and i was
totally into my brother because he sang
the beatles songs and the beatles were
you know my thing and i couldn't
understand like he just came from cuba
he speaks almost good english and he
sing all the beatles songs you know it
was like
wow you know that was cool
and so she leaves me at home with him
and my little sister
and um
in the middle of the night i
wake up
and he's on top of me going inside of me
and
got me you know covering my face and
just saying if if you tell anybody i'm
going to kill you
and um i remember looking over to the
bedroom window and
like i've
it was weird i looked over and i saw my
friend looking in the
window
that really didn't happen i learned that
later on in life but
that was like a way i removed myself
from what was happening and
you know in my mind i was like yeah as
long as you don't do it again you know
because i had been sexually abused but i
had never had penetration
and and you know he did that and it was
like
uh he never did do that again but he
could not live with himself and he had
to see me every single day in the
morning and daytime and my mom would
make him take me to the store and i
didn't want to go with him and so he's
the beatings began he was hitting me he
would take me and my mom would say oh
take her to the store she needs to get
out a little bit you know i'd be like i
don't want to go and so when you know
she'd say yeah you go and so when we get
outside he'd be like oh so you know what
i was telling me so he just started
whooping my butt all the way to the
store
and then he made me pull myself together
to go in the store and then whip my butt
on the way back you know so things were
getting really
like i remember when at breakfast time
one time we both reached for something
at the same time and he accidentally
like touched my hand and
and i just kind of like but he was like
enraged and he like picked up he threw
the dining table across the room and my
mom was like what's going on because i
didn't say anything
about what had happened
and i didn't wasn't sure what the term
or what you know what happened
so i called that my you know the last
foster parents that i was at and i i
just about three months later it was
crazy
and i said do you know what
the what rape means
you know and she goes yeah and i said i
think i think that happened to me i'm
not sure what i think
and pretty soon there's police
everywhere and
i was
my mom had already and him had already
labeled me kind of as like the crazy one
because i i was on medication
and
when i went from the foster home to
people united with my mom my mom
was told the social worker she wasn't
gonna give me medicine
and that was like the key that was the
number one thing that got me that was to
pulled it all together at that foster
home i finally could concentrate i
finally could feel good about school you
know everything i was working out my my
foster father built this beautiful pool
outside because i was a little chunky
and he'd have these games he'd throw
like these coins in the in these 50 cent
pieces in the pool and he'd be like get
it you know be like no i'm scared you
know and then you know i learned how to
dive and i go down there and pick you
know and he he just always had you know
these beautiful things
you know for
for me to do there were challenges but
he wanted me to exercise too because i
had a belly and stuff and that was the
way he did it can you tell me what you
said before we started about
how he reacted when your mom was taking
you away
oh gosh he was he was devastated he he
couldn't even talk to me
he was
and we resembled each other too uh
he was just the greatest thing you know
a
perfect perfect example of a good father
a man
you know husband a provider i mean just
a great great person uh if it wasn't for
for that man and and that lady i you
know i'm i'm not sure what
a mess i'd be today you know i'm a mess
but not not the ugly kind of mess
what was his reaction when you were
leaving
he he was devastating he was crying and
he was
just he couldn't talk he was beside
himself and he could not
there wasn't anything she was crying but
but i'm
the fact that he wasn't it you know told
me everything and you know
he dedicated his
every weekend to me there was no
question it wasn't even discussed
you know he'd say come on we're gonna go
do this and he could pack up the you
know the the car and we would go to
areas like this and we'd fly these we
used to get in these little glider like
planes and just kind of float around and
and we had he had boats that they were
you know we'd go to these places that
had like a bunch of people would be
there with their boats and their
airplanes and stuff
just so much fun and he he
took me to scary things you know scary
things like drag car erases you know and
put a hat on me and i'd be like
it's kind of scary in my ear you know
and he'd like give me all this
protection stuff but you know but then
he'd look at me like
yeah you know he was he just
marvin his name was marvin but i never
got to talk to them again
ever
i never got to tell them thank you
i thought they didn't have to recall
to me that call
somehow i did i had done something wrong
never been loved like that you know like
that before
but i know he knows
he knows how much i loved him and her
and
you know how important they were in my
life too
and it was like going to be with them
was was a
i remember the challenge because when i
told my sister go and half the way home
in the cottage she was in a different
college and i was like kill that girl
i i have a home i'm gonna go to you know
to
she's like you're going to leave me
you're going to leave me and i said i'll
come back and get you
but they said that she wasn't ready
she was ready to go
no i don't think that's what it was i
think you know they wanted one kid you
know and that's and and that was great
you know because that was
making sure you know what i'm saying i
mean
my life was their life you know
and they took really good care of me and
they they disciplined me when i you know
got in trouble
uh she had me in catholic school
and i got in trouble i remember that
uh
i was like a picky eater i used to eat
rocks and um dirt i i was one of those
kids that had a spoon like carved in a
in the wall outside and i'd go out there
every chance i couldn't eat this you
know this stuff and it tasted delicious
to this day
you know i i was pregnant i went one of
my pregnancies i ate magnesium and i
told the doctor i have something to tell
you i i went to the store and i bought
this stuff that gymnasts use on their
hands
and i slice it up like butter and i get
that and a big bag of ice next to me and
i just sit there and chomp on it and it
tastes so good i go but what am i doing
you know
he says no you it's actually okay your
body's probably craving magnesium or
something but you're gonna have a real
clean baby you know and for sure when
she was born she just like
he's 15 minutes after i got to the
hospital i had her
you know
[Music]
i was married at 15
when i was
finally you know reunited with my mom
and everything
my brother went to jail he went to jail
for like five years i think um
and it was it was a horrible thing and
it's been horrible forever because
um i came home from school one day
and that's you know i was already out of
that foster home and stuff
and my mom's making him dinner he's he's
sitting at the table like a king and and
i opened the door you know to come in
from school and i was like
you know and he's like hi you know you
know like
it was really hard you know and my mom
was like say hi to your brother you know
i was like i didn't understand what
happened like
why is he here
you know and is he gonna sleep here and
and move in you know but somebody i
think was monitoring that
he was allowed to visit but he wasn't
you know he never did live with us but
he turned out to be paranoid
schizophrenic
he was diagnosed later on in life but to
this day probably if i saw him if i ran
into him right now he would
grab me by the hair or you know do
something to me like uh
look at your hair you know or like one
time i cut my hair real short shirt you
know i was at my mom's doing the dishes
and he came in
and he stood behind me and he just
started insulting me and i was like
i just turned i mean married with kids
and everything you know what i'm saying
and he says um
you cut your hair what kind of an idiot
does that woman's hair is her crown or
her
what and i was like what the hell is he
talking to her you know but he he still
had this weird you know thing
and he would
imagine think things and think they
happen and really believe it you know i
didn't know too much about it then i did
later on in life learned a lot about
so you you were married young oh yeah i
got married at age 15.
uh
i met this man
at church and um
he like was head over heels you know and
he was like 23 24
and
i like the attention and everything and
you know on sunday mornings my sister my
sister would go and see his his brother
and my sister thought if i could take my
sister my mom i could be gone longer
so
my mom started you know she's like yeah
so
i would get in his car and he'd drive
around all santa monica and all this
stuff you know and then um you know one
day i saw him with somebody and i was
like how come you
you say you're my boyfriend and stuff
and i hadn't had a boyfriend
and he i go but i see with this other
this ladies person he goes oh he goes
well
okay he goes i i'm a man and i have
these needs and you know
uh i go and he goes but if if i if i get
those needs from you then i don't i
won't you know i don't have to be with
anybody else and i said okay
and so he goes really and i said yeah
sure
so i had him bring me a calendar and i i
closed my eyes and i went like this and
i you know like picked it a day it was
like almost a whole year
ahead i mean a from that date so
i i got a break you know for for that
whole year but their time approached and
got closer and closer and
uh when i did i had to i had to deliver
and and got pregnant
and so by that time i i was still on
probation i i literally was finishing my
school college at my high school
sitting next to my probation officer
because i ran away every day to go to
the beach i'd take my bus money buy a
pack of cigarettes and i use a
skateboard and i was cool i was at the
beach all day long tan you know i had a
nice time and
was ditching school so i sat literally
next to her in santa monica she was
another great person in my life too uh
and did my school there and then
when i told her i'm gonna have a baby
you know
uh
she was like shucks because you never
talked to me about abortion i said i
know
it just happened you know
so she said um she was talking about
emancipation and i said what does that
mean she goes well
it would be that he your
he would be your your father or your uh
what's it called like your guardian you
know so she yeah she allowed me to sign
the paper where she would but there was
a condition i had to go to college i had
to he she was worried because i was
going to have this baby and i was only
15 and kind of
michael so um that was a condition that
i would take some courses on child
development and all that which was a
great thing because later on in life it
you know it really worked out for me to
have
have that under my belt and i got a lot
of credit i got you know paid well for
my experience because i didn't have any
college i took a few little courses that
was it but it was it paid off she was
smart
you know that was good
but yeah that marriage was um
uh also kind of weird
yeah uh
you know when you grow up
sexually abusing stuff
you don't
enjoy sex you know what i'm saying you
really don't enjoy sex
um
it's like
you block your you know block it all out
and everything and
i don't i i think it's the husband gets
cheated you know too because it takes a
long time to get to
you know
to where you you know you're okay with
that and or
you allow yourself to you know
to enjoy your your sex and everything
but
um i had two daughters with out of that
marriage and then i had a i have five
kids uh another daughter out of wedlock
and then i got married and had the two
boys that i have five kids
your kids are doing well
uh most of them are yeah
yeah
good good very good kids good people you
know uh loving and caring and you raised
them all
yeah
uh they also when i got divorced from my
first husband
he made it a point to you know to take
him to take the girls and little by
little he did
uh
bribery you know bribing and stuff
but um
like i said i was 15 i was 16 when i had
my first one and right now i think i'm
65 or 66 and she's
pushing 50 i think you know so yeah
that's kind of odd i have one great
grandbaby
do you have any regrets in your life
i regret
being stubborn and
you know not worrying about a drug use
you know thinking that well because i
you know i i had good jobs i worked at
the function i had really really good
jobs
and nobody ever knew that was that was
my biggest downfall is that nobody ever
knew i was a drug addict
oh really so when when drugs come into
your life i was about about 11.
oh really yeah i was a runaway and
somebody on the streets you know said
yeah he goes you know you you have to
buy and i said i have to keep walking i
can't because the cops get you you know
and i wasn't going to like dye my hair
and make myself a different person so i
just kept you know going in he said well
these will help you know this will help
you
so he gave me some some meth
and
when i took them
these were pills when i took them it was
like the medication that i
used to take it was like
wow okay this is this is right this is
exactly
what i need so the journey began then
you know
and then you know being a runaway you
run into a lot of
is on the streets and everything like
that and like i said i was safe but it
was a very normal common thing to be
high all the time i always had drugs i
always had people would give me stuff
and you know sometimes i'd do it
sometimes i wouldn't
is the drug use continuing to this point
it has yes really throughout your life
pretty much pretty much yeah yeah i have
off and on
you know times which what drugs like
methamphetamine uh
marijuana
alcohol but like today it's still meth
yes well if i if i
if i was i mean i tried to say no but
you know it doesn't always work out like
that for me and i'm not making any
excuses or anything for the you know the
situation that i'm in but it kind of
helps just a little bit because
you're not as tired so you don't require
a lot of sleep so you're not
uncomfortable
you know because
it can get uncomfortable at night so if
you don't have to worry about sleeping
then you know but it's not it's you've
been through your life you're a
functional addict yes you've had jobs
and raised kids and all that yes
yeah but i don't i don't like that's
that's the regret right there is that
you don't want to be a functional drug
addict you know
you want it not to not to work for you
but it did you know
it made me real good at my jobs you know
i had supervisor jobs i
you know i got every job i've ever
applied for i've gotten
you know and not everybody can say that
you know
and uh
i really i wish i was younger now you
know i think if i was a little bit
younger and and as mad as because i am
really mad right now about my situation
um
i think i would just be like working
working working you know
and and starting all over again you know
but i had gotten to a point like at age
19 i had i already had two daught two
kids i had like thousands of dollars in
the bank i had a brand new car good job
and i didn't know what to do next
it was like
i'm not sure you know like
this can't be all you know i don't want
to be
you know i'm a millionaire or whatever
you know but i
i got to do something you know and then
there was no
guidance or no example or no um
my husband just really didn't have that
drive you know he was okay with how we
were you know managing an
apartment
and i was like i did a lot of weird
things with him too because like
i was used to like every five six months
i relocated and it wasn't my fault it
was like okay today you know
and uh i would literally twice i
actually moved out
and moved us out of one place and into
another place by the time he got out of
work it's like okay we don't live there
there's getting out on the door look
this is arnold around just like are you
crazy what i mean you know
and i'd get it done you know
but i had a i like to socialize you know
and i had a lot of i used to like
impress people because i used to make
hors d'oeuvres and you know serve them
entrees and stuff
and i i like to have my little drink at
five o'clock you know because everybody
drank a martini or something you know
but your life has been good sounds like
i i think so i you seem very positive
yes yes uh
there's so much good out there there
really is there because you could easily
have seen that you're a victim and
focused on the things that happened to
you and setbacks you know something
always
would happen in my mind like whenever i
told you the window um
when something would happen to me it was
like my mind would go i would be like
that fire starter kid and i i'd say but
you're not going to change who i am or
who i'm going to be because i'm not her
yet you know and and that's like that's
the drive i've had and i know now i know
that to get some kind of gift because
you know i
and then working with you know
you don't allow yourself to be a victim
no you can't if you do that then you're
like
you kind of like you settled you kind of
settled you know
and i worked with a lot of moms who
yeah you know
did they the victim thing worked for
them you know it doesn't work for me i
don't think that i could be enough of a
victim to get have any gain or like this
is not good okay you know i'd rather be
you know strong when i i helped a lot of
females
i am proud very proud of that you know i
remember the first time i helped
somebody
leave an abusive situation and it was
like
it was like the book you know teaches
you you know you get them to give
to put away belongings and you know
things like that and then one day they
slip out and they got you know and i
remember because her husband stayed
stayed in the neighborhood and said he'd
be like do you seem like you're gonna be
like no i haven't but she she did great
after that you know she got a little
girls out of you know he was very he
used to hit them and stuff her too
and um
it was like i felt so good but i had i
couldn't tell anybody it was a big
secret you know
but i i saw my potential at that time of
of helping you know
and i love being out there i love being
out there and
you know
not
you know what you do but you know uh
i see beautiful beautiful things and
like that you know video i was telling
you i was watching
and um
there's just so yeah there's bad crazy
things going on and everything and you
know we all have to understand that the
world is
it is it's like a like an explosion you
know of pain and and
uh worry and concern and everything and
a lot of things happen you know like
yeah we've
we're in the situation that we're in
like right now because
as when kobet hit all these boom things
happen one after another
somebody somebody robbed they took our
took our trailer with all of our
belongings in it even our animals they
took our cat and our dog
okay we were packed ready to go because
we were going to go to mexico
you know with a friend
and um
we were we ended up in the hospital and
then when we went to the hospital and
everybody's wearing masculine we just
heard about the covet
and
just sold our house we had a house in
whitewood
and sold it and
now we're paying like fifteen hundred
dollars a week on a motel room we
couldn't get any people were getting
vouchers and stuff all over the place
but because we weren't from the city
that we were in
uh we couldn't help we couldn't get help
and i wasn't about to like lie and okay
here they wanted my birth certificate
and they wanted my like proof that i had
been raised in this upland and you know
these areas
that uh they want to report cards you
know stuff like that it's like oh man
just
yeah so it uh
it took a lot of extra money
iris what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
life
i've learned not to be judgmental and
you know to
uh
pray and be real just be real with your
heart when you when you do something for
somebody
do it don't even think about it you know
what i'm saying and don't stop yourself
when like i'm like i'm like
what they you call you know somebody
that doesn't think before they do
something you know and every once in a
while you know like but you don't do it
you don't stop you just it's done you
know and it feels good
you know and it's it's
worth it it's just so worth it and
sometimes it's just the little things
you know
uh just somebody to know that you know
you're there or
uh
but you understand that you care you
know uh i like to see i like to i like
it when i know that somebody's thirsty
you know
like hey ask anybody let's see oh yeah
go in there she'll feed you you know
because i like i get i'll get the
kitchen you know thing going up that's
why my hands are all messed up right now
because i have the fire going you know
and i cook i i it'll be like the middle
of the night and i'll be like
so you know so i just put this fire on
and start making this stuff you know and
and
it gives me joy i got that from my mom
too
i learned how to cook cuban food for my
mom
and i learned a lot my mom was a very he
died not that long ago but she was very
very honest she was one of those people
loyal and honest to
what other people would be saying like
to a
a you know not a good thing you know
just too much you know but yeah to a
fault there you go and uh she i remember
one time
somebody she had these two friends and
they were having affairs with their you
know each other or whatever and one lady
came up she comes in she my mom stopped
she goes uh
you will not come here and talk to me
about her she's my friend too you know
she i saw her doing this all the time
and and she had a lot of male friends
who you know cubans and and they they go
to her and they say lelia you know a man
look what's going on in my life and you
know she just always had an answer for
them you know and everybody in the
neighborhood love you go go to my mom's
house and have coffee anytime and she
was very tender very loving and very uh
very giving
and
you could tell
she had a very very hard life her life
was hard
yeah she actually
i i found out
probably
10 years ago maybe
that
her father
had a child with one of her sisters
you know
yeah and this child
barely i think passed away like a year
or so ago so she was like in her age
you know
yeah and she had my mom had a baby at
13. her father took her somewhere she
had to get rid of it and then she had a
brother
who has you know mental illness runs in
our family you know addiction and mental
illness
big time
but uh i can't imagine she was a servant
in a in in homes at age 10 age eight
she never went to school
yeah she had beautiful beautiful blue
eyes
and dark dark skin
yeah she danced and
sang everything yeah
i i feel like i didn't have her a lot of
time you know
but at the time that i did it was
very
like
worth it you know a lot
i consolidated
you know
i was real mean to her a lot of times
too
she didn't understand i remember and i
never meant to insult her but i i was
trying to tell her in an educated way
that when you don't know something it
makes you it means that you're ignorant
you know and she's like but but you're
insulting me you're telling me i'm
ignorant i said but not in that way i
said that's how i was taught
she had a real hard time understanding
like
our differences and how you know we were
raised my mom wanted you know and she
was very disappointed in all of us and
all of her kids because we
she came to
five you know drug or four drug addicted
you know alcoholics or crazy you know
angry you know and she couldn't
understand you know she would say like
if i knew you guys were going to turn
out to be like that i never would you
know would have sent you you know but
you know and then she you know she had a
hard time listening we were very
opposite my mom used to always say you'd
be discreet don't talk about those
things to people you know and i said but
i have to it's part of me i have to you
know say and she used to
think it was mean that i would say you
know to people i would want you know
what don't leave your little kid with my
brother just don't you know because um
he's not well
you know and my mom would say you know
that wasn't the right thing to do
and i i had a i mean for a long time i
had to
it was a battle you know like don't
because you're putting your family down
you know
so
anyways all right well iris thank you so
much for sharing your story
thank you for interviewing me you're
very interesting
so are you
you